improvising on stage is malian jazz
artist pedro kuyati
[Music]
with a band of senegalese musicians
taken by the music many in the crowd are
unable to keep still
among them melinda and richard who
traveled across the atlantic from
washington dc to attend the event this
music is really at the root of jazz this
is where jazz came from
originating with the griot tradition
where people chanted their stories of
their families
and they used traditional instruments to
accompany it
and what eventually became american jazz
had its roots here in africa in
particular west africa
and we're from washington d.c where
there's a strong jazz
that music scene and we go to it a lot
we really enjoy it so we thought it'd be
interesting to come back and get a
deeper understanding of where jazz comes
from and how it sounds here
with covid restrictions lifted this 30th
edition of the san luis jazz festival is
bringing hundreds of visitors the
archipelago is a unesco world heritage
site during the second world war
african-american troops landed in this
former colonial capital of french africa
bringing their music explains the
festival director
from the mississippi river to here there
is a flow of music perhaps african
slaves brought their music to america
and african americans brought it back
here in this dialogue there is this
sound this voice that feels like a
divine melody malianartes cuyante wishes
there could be a festival like this in
war-torn mali or ukraine
[Music]
jazz is freedom it allows you to escape
to be free from the blues and leave your
worries behind
sounds from the balafini
and the angoni
transport the audience in a musical
journey
let me show you the instruments that he
has on stage he's been using just before
he picked up the guitar akora which is a
10-string instrument and then on stage
there's also a calabasas which is
another traditional west african
instrument and this is what this
festival is about is to introduce
afro-jazz to a wider public right here
in san lui
[Music]
this is a celebration of music
of love and of the joy it brings to
people
no matter where they're from
nicholas hawk al jazeera saint louis
senegal